are you still playing pokemon go well if
you are developer niantic labs has
released a new update which ad feat
pokemon appraisal feature players will
be able to use it to learn about a
pokemons attack and defense capabilities
as measured by their team leader I'm
Lucy and welcome to your if that's
another sodding drowsy i'm going to
uninstall this app gamespot news update
it's implied that the trainer tips
feature is only available to players who
have reached at least level five and
chosen a faction to side with team
mystic team valor or team instinct a
pokemons attack and defense statistics
have influence over how well it will
perform in battle as you can see in the
screenshots here the appraisal feature
provides an overview of the statistics
as opposed to sharing the actual numbers
in addition the update adds minor bot
fixes develop atlantic has said it is
still working on several new and
exciting features to be implemented in
the game recently niantic announced its
intention to take action against players
who were cheating in Pokemon go the
developer has begun issuing permanent
bands to players who used wat programs
such as GPS roofers players who have
been determined as cheetahs will receive
an email informing of the termination of
their account but if you've been banned
and you think you shouldn't have been
you can file a support ticket with the
Pokemon go help center to get the
reinstatement process started so are you
flying the flag for mystic valla or
instinct what do you think is missing
from Pokemon go let me know in the
comments below or come find me on
Twitter I'm at Lucy James games for more
on pokémon go make she keep it gamespot